Skee-ball is my life. I met my wife playing skee-ball. Skee-ball has had a material impact on my life,
and I want to share that with others. And this space will be a conduit for that.
Joey Mucha is a three-time skee-ball national champion and the owner of Joey the Cat,
an arcade rental repair and events company that he started in 2010.
Building my business started out as a side project to my day job. I bought at that skee-ball machine on eBay
to practice and then had to learn how to repair it. So the natural progression was to put it in a bar,
see if it could make some recurring revenue, and then use that money to buy another skee-ball machine.
In 2014 Mucha purchased this warehouse in San Francisco's Mission District
as a repair and storage facility. In 2019 he decided to convert it into an arcade and restaurant,
which should have been a straightforward process since the property was already zoned
for commercial use. But a community activist incurring nothing more than a $600 fee
was able to temporarily scuttle Mucha's plans, forcing him to spend months rallying community support
and pleading his case at a public hearing. Joey the Cat's new outpost is slated to open in spring of 2021.
But the story of how the project was nearly stopped, and what Mucha endured in order to prevail
underscores how even the most benign land-use changes in San Francisco can be hampered by red tape.
It's a root cause of the city's housing crisis and jeopardizes San Francisco's competitiveness
over the long term. Joey the Cat should be renamed Joey the liar.
This is within 500 feet of an elementary school. We're talking about proximity to schools,
we don't need young people walking by that and seeing these negative toxic images.
I'm not converting this to a private event space only for corporates, I'm converting this to a public space
that can be used by all. In a perfect world if there was no red tape we would have been open six months ago.
Mucha's troubles started when Kevin Ortiz, a local activist affiliated with the anti-gentrification group,
Cultural Action Network, filed an application for discretionary review, a process through which
any member of the public can ask the San Francisco Planning Commission to review an application
for a building permit. Neither Ortiz nor Cultural Action Network responded to our interview requests.
Even though these reviews are supposed to be used only under exceptional and extraordinary circumstances
they've become a regular part of the city's land use process.
For example, the owner of a falafel restaurant was able to delay the opening of a competitor
by claiming that the neighborhood already had enough falafel. This homes third floor addition was blocked
on the grounds that it wasn't sufficiently Victorian. The conversion of a laundromat to an apartment building
has been delayed for over five years due in part to its casting a shadow on an already shaded school yard.
So far in 2019 the Planning Commission publicly heard 91 requests for discretionary review.
Because every building permit in the city is subject to this process. It adds enormous cost to construction,
exacerbating the city's severe housing shortage.
Mucha prevailed by devoting enormous time to winning over community support,
which otherwise would have gone into running his business.
I've basically become a politician, which I don't want to become. And I don't want that for anyone.
I've watched a bunch of Planning Commission hearings and research to kind of understand the concept,
because small business owners shouldn't be flung into this process and expected to be perfect at this
when the activists are going to these almost weekly.
I've gotten a profile on all the different planning commissioners, I know their names.
I know kind of what they vote for and against. My team and I went and garnered as much support as we could
from the community and we've worked with architects and had to figure out
how to make this space work for both what I want it to be and what is legally permitted
and make good business sense out of it. And finding that triangulation is incredibly complex and challenging
and has been very burdensome process for a small business owner.
Mucha went door-to-door in the mission asking for help from his neighbors.
At the hearing more than twice as many supporters as opponents came out to  speak.
Joey the Cat is fun for both adults and children,
and more importantly it is kept clean and it is a safe environment,
which is more than I can say for some of the parks and our neighborhood.
Political connections also came into play. Mucha received a letter of support from California
State Treasurer Fiona Ma, who once held a fundraiser at Joey's arcade. On a principled level
I think it's so hard for a small business owner to be successful in this city and when you start to layer on
red tape, or these hurdles and roadblocks that come out of personal interests or community interests
that don't necessarily align with the business, it makes it very difficult. And I think it's something
that should be changed at a policy level.